who he played for Aaron Rodgers let's go
with the Jets I want to hear some
clapping back there obj I don't know I
stopped following him when he left where
did he go obj with the Ravens really
went to the Raven oh my God I brought
some oh my God wait did you just miss
you sir oh I don't care
Cardinals Patriots Patriots
Jalen Ramsey with the dolphins dolphins
oh Miami he went to the Dolphins Baron
Wallace oh my God no he oh Giants Giants
oh Giants Sam darnold Sam darnold live
he probably went to the Raiders Sam
darnold went to the 49ers Brandon
McManus where'd he go he left Denver
Jacksonville Jaguars maybe Jacksonville
Jacksonville yeah
Washington football team commanders he
went to Washington yo Jacoby yo we
appreciate you for everything that you
did even though that you knew that you
weren't gonna be that starting man you
still gave us that starting performance
we love you we appreciate everything
that you did for us bro